Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家透露一件现在正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造能够为你工作的收入，而不是不断用时间去换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主导的“冲刺持续性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. How would you know if you were heading towards burnout? What would the signs and symptoms
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的精美奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特ント博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一一小时辅导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有细节告诉你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正走向精疲力竭，你会如何察觉？会有哪些迹象和症状
be? Might other people notice before you? And once you recognize the signs and symptoms, how can you step back to make positive changes for yourself or for those that you care about? That is the topic of this brilliant podcast episode, which is a special on burnout. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now, it's pretty on brand today that I am in my gym gear and I am off ready to go personal training. It's one of the things that keeps me really well. And it's one of the top tips that's mentioned towards the end of this episode, which is one of our special Burnout Bites series, which is beautifully presented for us by Dr. Claire Plumley. Claire is the author of a brilliant new book all about burnout and how to reduce it. There are details in the show notes. This is episode four of the Burnout Bites series. There is no need to watch them all, but they do piece
呢？别人会不会比你更早注意到？一旦你识别出这些迹象和症状，你该如何退一步，为自己或你关心的人做出积极的改变？这就是这期精彩播客节目的主题，这是一期关于职业倦怠的特别节目。希望你觉得它非常有用。嗨，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安·特ント博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我穿着健身装备，准备去上私人教练课，这非常符合我的风格。这是让我保持健康的方法之一，也是本集节目接近尾声时提到的首要建议之一。这是我们特别的“倦怠点滴”（Burnout Bites）系列节目之一，由克莱尔·普拉姆利博士（Dr. Claire Plumley）为我们精彩呈现。克莱尔是一本关于倦怠及其如何减少倦怠的精彩新书的作者。节目说明中有详细信息。这是“倦怠点滴”系列的第四集。没有必要把它们全部看完，但它们确实
together beautifully to help you to really thicken your understanding of what burnout is and how to avoid it in yourself and those that you care about or work with. Hopefully we care about the people we work with too. Let's dive in and see what these stages are, how we can notice what burnout is as it develops so we can stand a chance of catching it in its tracks. I will catch you on the other side. Hello and welcome back to Burnout Bites. This is episode four of a short series of six episodes designed to help you understand more about burnout so you can look after yourself and anyone in your clinical practice as well. My name is Dr. Claire Plumley and I'm a clinical psychologist. I
完美地拼凑在一起，帮助你真正加深对什么是倦怠以及如何在自己、你关心的人或共事的人身上避免倦怠的理解。希望我们也关爱共事的人。让我们深入探讨这些阶段是什么，如何在倦怠发展时注意到它，以便我们有机会将其扼杀在萌芽状态。我们稍后见。你好，欢迎回到“倦怠点滴”。这是由六集组成的短系列的第四集，旨在帮助你更多地了解倦怠，以便你也能照顾好自己以及临床实践中的任何人。我叫克莱尔·普拉姆利博士，我是一名临床心理学家。我
specialize in trauma, anxiety and burnout and I run my own practice in Taunton, Somerset and online with a group of associates. Recently I've written a book available now you can link to it in the show notes it's called Burnout how to manage your nervous system before it manages you. In today's episode I'm going to bring you the five stage model of burnout. Now there are different stage models as there are for most different concepts different ways of understanding things including a 12 model, which I don't talk about in my book because my mind boggles a bit if I try to wrap my head around remembering 12 stages. I find this five-stage model a really handy way of understanding it. It depicts the progression from no stress into stress, chronic stress, and then tipping into burnout. This is a
专注于创伤、焦虑和倦怠，我在萨默塞特郡汤顿以及线上与一群同事共同经营着自己的诊所。最近我写了一本新书，现在已经上市，你可以在节目说明中找到链接，书名叫《倦怠：在神经系统管理你之前如何管理它》（Burnout: How to manage your nervous system before it manages you）。在今天的节目中，我将为大家介绍倦怠的五个阶段模型。现在，正如大多数不同概念一样，存在着不同的阶段模型，有不同的理解方式，包括一个12阶段模型，我在书中没有谈到它，因为如果我试图记住12个阶段，我的大脑会有点懵。我发现这个五阶段模型是一个非常方便的理解方式。它描绘了从无压力到压力、慢性压力，然后陷入倦怠的发展过程。这是一个
model that was developed in 1980 and was first written about in a nursing magazine, an occupational nursing magazine by Robert Van Inger and Dr. James Spagli. They were trying to understand the progression from job satisfaction into job disillusionment and how this was often followed by, as they were stating in this article, physical and mental health difficulties, which then just swamp and overwhelm the individual. It's a fairly well referenced model in regards to burnout these days. Hold in mind that stage models can oversimplify things and they can suggest a linear trajectory through each stage into the next one and often we might oscillate between them but I'm sure you would have that awareness of stage models anyway. So stage one is the honeymoon stage. I'm going to go through each stage and I'm going to explain what it is and the signs that you might be here. And then we can think at the end of this episode about what you might need to do at each point. Stage one is the honeymoon stage. At this
在1980年开发的模型，最初由罗伯特·范·因格（Robert Van Inger）和詹姆斯·斯帕格利博士（Dr. James Spagli）在一本护理杂志、一本职业护理杂志上撰文介绍。他们试图了解从对工作的满意度到对工作幻灭的过程，以及正如他们在文章中所述，这通常是如何伴随着身心健康困难的，这些困难随后会淹没并压倒个人。如今，关于倦怠，这是一个引用率相当高的模型。请记住，阶段模型可能会过度简化事情，它们可能会暗示通过每个阶段进入下一个阶段的线性轨迹，通常我们可能会在它们之间摇摆不定，但我确信你无论如何都会对阶段模型有所了解。所以第一阶段是蜜月期。我将经历每个阶段，我将解释它是什么以及你可能处于这里的迹象。然后我们可以在本集结束时思考你在每个时间点可能需要做什么。第一阶段是蜜月期。在这个
stage, you generally feel pretty satisfied with what you're doing and achieving. Energy levels and enthusiasm might be high. So you're driven, maybe enthusiastic, and you wouldn't necessarily think of yourself as potentially burning out because you don't have any of the signs of distress. So actually, you're not burning out right now. However, it's important to know about this stage because you can prevent yourself progressing to the next one with some gentle interventions. I tend to notice when I'm like this, I'm really struggling to pace myself. I'm often very, very excited by projects. I'm saying yes to everything because I want a bite of every pie. So you'll recognize you're here if you feel any of what I've just described, that kind of enthusiasm.
阶段，你通常对你正在做的事情和取得的成就感到相当满意。精力和热情可能会很高。所以你很有动力，也许很热情，你不会必然认为自己可能会精疲力竭，因为你没有任何痛苦的迹象。所以实际上，你现在并没有精疲力竭。然而，了解这个阶段很重要，因为你可以通过一些温和的干预措施来防止自己发展到下一个阶段。当我处于这种状态时，我往往会注意到我真的很难掌控自己的节奏。我经常对项目感到非常非常兴奋。我对所有事情都说“好”，因为我想分一杯羹。因此，如果你感觉到我刚描述的任何情况，那种热情，你就会认出你在这里。
You're saying yes to too many things. You're kind of excited and rushing and you're feeling really positive about outcomes. Not really think about the practicalities of how you will reach them. You might also start to drop other things in the pursuit of these goals. So for example, your boring admin, life admin, hobbies or social connections, and maybe your boundaries between work and life start to get blurred. So for example, when I was doing my studying to become a psychologist, often I found at every moment of the day, I had a workbook in my bag to pull out and read and these days of course we have our phones with us we can easily dip into reading something
你对太多事情说“好”。你有点兴奋和匆忙，你对结果感到非常积极。并没有真正考虑你将如何实现它们的实际情况。在追求这些目标的过程中，你可能还会开始放弃其他事情。例如，你枯燥的行政工作、生活行政、爱好或社交联系，也许你工作与生活之间的界限开始变得模糊。例如，当我努力成为一名心理学家时，我经常发现一天中的每一刻，我的包里都有一本练习册拿出来阅读，当然，现在我们随身带着手机，我们可以轻松地开始阅读某些内容
or checking emails so it's all of this feels kind of almost easy and like you're really wanting to get into work and so boundaries are very hard to kind of hold in place. Stage two this is the onset of stress so projects might start to lose their shine as the reality of the demand start to kick in. So there are some very common external stresses at this point that might highlight this stage as being relevant to you. So this is when we might notice having too much to do or that we're being deprived of having agency choosing how we want to do those things. So our choice feels curtailed. You might feel criticised or like your efforts aren't actually being rewarded or appreciated. Could feel like
或者查看电子邮件，所以这一切感觉几乎很容易，而且你真的很想投入到工作中，因此界限很难保持在原地。第二阶段，这是压力的开始：随着需求的现实开始显现，项目可能开始失去光彩。所以在这个时候有一些非常常见的外部压力，可能会突出这个阶段与你相关。因此，这就是我们可能注意到有太多事情要做，或者我们被剥夺了选择我们想要如何做这些事情的自主权的时候。所以我们的选择感觉受到限制。你可能会感到受到批评，或者觉得你的努力实际上并没有得到回报或赞赏。可能感觉像
you're being unfairly treated or that you're unsupported in everything you're doing. If you don't have any buffers to stress in place, which of course if you remember in stage one might have gone if you're not having those boundaries and that downtime, those social connections, then your body might start to react even more with the stress responses. So signs that you are here, you're getting more irritable or impatient on issues that are pretty minor, like being asked a favor or someone's walking too slowly, or my classic is when I'm queuing. Your brain might start to race, or you might start to find the worries are really hard to dismiss. You might find it hard to switch off. So you might want to rest or sleep, start to find the worries are really hard to dismiss. You might find it hard to
你受到不公正的对待，或者你在所做的一切中都得不到支持。如果你没有建立对压力的缓冲，当然，如果你还记得如果在第一阶段你没有那些界限和停机时间、那些社交联系，那么你的身体可能会以更强烈的方式对压力做出反应。所以你在这里的迹象是：对于相当小的事情，你变得更加易怒或不耐烦，比如被要求帮个忙，或者有人走得太慢，或者我的经典例子是我在排队时。你的大脑可能会开始飞速运转，或者你可能会发现担忧真的很难消除。你可能会发现很难关掉大脑。所以你可能想休息或睡觉，开始发现担忧真的很难消除。你可能会发现很难
switch off. So you might want to rest or sleep but you're finding that really challenging to do. And as before you're neglecting things, maybe your personal needs. You're finding it hard to tune into your stress, maybe rushing around and not really noticing how tense or overwhelmed you're beginning to feel. Stage three. This is chronic stress. So your initial stress isn't addressed. If your initial stress feeling isn't addressed, the longer lasting physical impacts of stress start to take their toll. So you might start to notice even more signs that you are in that fight or flight part of your nervous system. So you're overreacting really quickly with anxiety or annoyance. You might have even panic
关掉大脑。所以你可能想休息或睡觉，但你发现这真的很有挑战性。和以前一样，你忽略了一些事情，也许是你的个人需求。你发现很难调入你的压力，也许四处奔忙，却没有真正注意到你开始感到多么紧张或不知所措。第三阶段。这是慢性压力。所以你最初的压力没有得到解决。如果你最初的压力感没有得到解决，压力的长期身体影响开始显现。所以你可能会开始注意到更多迹象，表明你处于神经系统的战斗或逃跑部分。所以你对焦虑或烦恼的反应非常快。你甚至可能会恐慌
attacks or bouts of irritability or just feeling almost paralyzed and frozen. You might get physical signs, you know, headaches, back pain, you might start catching colds more easily or have reduced libido. And the cognitive signs of this difficulty making decisions, difficulty focusing or concentrating or something. So classic is going into a room, forgetting why you're there, being halfway through a task and getting distracted, moving on. So you have lots of unfinished tasks. And your coping for stress that's unhealthy might be more obvious at this point. So classic for me might be doom scrolling, procrastinating, seeking more reassurance, like checking in with my other half or with colleagues,
发作、易怒发作，或者只是感觉几乎瘫痪和呆滞。你可能会出现身体迹象，你知道的，头痛、背痛，你可能会更容易感冒或性欲减退。这种困难的认知迹象是：难以做决定、难以专注或集中注意力等等。所以经典的是走进一个房间，忘记你在那里做什么，进行到一半的任务时分心，然后继续前进。所以你有很多未完成的任务。此时你对不健康压力的应对可能会更加明显。所以对我来说，典型的可能是无休止地刷手机、拖延、寻求更多安心，比如向另一半或同事核实，
like if everything's okay. And as I mentioned in a previous episode, a classic for me is also impulse online shopping, of course, but that might look different for different people. I also tend to find I go into a bit of a zone out place where I'm, it's also very common to really struggle to switch your body into a mode where you can rest. So this can lead to real extra difficulties falling asleep or staying asleep. Many people find it really hard to admit to themselves just how stressed they are. Stage four is when we actually reach burnout. But in my mind, this is high functioning burnout. So you might be able to still do all the things that you normally do, but you're starting to feel
就像一切是否都好一样。正如我在前一集所提到的，对我也很典型的是冲动网上购物，当然，但这对于不同的人来说可能看起来不同。我也往往发现自己进入了一种有点脱离现实的状态，在这个状态下，也很常见的是很难让你的身体进入可以休息的模式。这会导致入睡或保持睡眠出现额外的真正困难。许多人发现很难向自己承认他们有多大压力。第四阶段是我们真正达到倦怠的时候。但在我看来，这是高功能倦怠。所以你可能仍然能够做你通常做的所有事情，但你开始感到
just wrung out. So perhaps decisions just feel almost like overwhelming, like you just can't make any. And this could be simple things like what to have for dinner, or whether you're going to attend something or not. You might also find that you're comparing yourself unfavorably to others. So this is that difficulty with personal accomplishment. We tend to assume that others are looking down on us, we feel less able and confident in our abilities. And we can't identify with others who are really at the same level as us because they just feel like they're on a different planet. So again, all the same signs here as the stress before.
精疲力竭。也许做决定几乎让人不知所措，好像你根本无法做决定。这可能是简单的事情，比如晚饭吃什么，或者你是否要参加某项活动。你还可能会发现你将自己与他人进行不利的比较。这就是个人成就感的困难。我们往往认为别人看不起我们，我们对自己的能力感到缺乏能力和自信。我们无法认同那些真正处于与我们相同水平的人，因为他们感觉就像在不同的星球上一样。所以同样，这里的所有迹象都与之前的压力相同。
But everything, if you imagine your body is kind of whispering to you before, everything's dialed up. So those aches and pains and niggles are harder to distract yourself from. You might be feeling even more, you might be noticing even more frequent and louder types of negative thoughts about how critical you are of yourself, your abilities, about others not being there for you, feeling unable to reach out for that support. You might be making more mistakes. So cognitively, you're less sharp and efficient and able. You might be forgetting to do things or ordering the wrong items and this is where you might also begin to feel really cynical or resentful towards others or the work you're being asked to do mood can also drop so
但是一切，如果你想象你的身体之前有点在对你低语，一切都被调高了。所以那些酸痛和刺痛更难分散你的注意力。你可能会感到更多，你可能会注意到关于你对自己、你的能力多么挑剔、关于别人没有为你提供支持、感到无法寻求这种支持的更频繁、更响亮的负面想法。你可能会犯更多错误。所以在认知上，你的敏锐度、效率和能力都会下降。你可能会忘记做事或订购错误的物品，这也是你可能开始对他人或被要求做的工作感到真正愤世嫉俗或怨恨的地方。情绪也可能会下降，所以
you might begin to feel really trapped unable to imagine how to break free this is where you get those escapism thoughts about how you could actually escape from what you're doing. Now, transition points in the day are often a good marker of this. If you think about the moment you finish doing something like for me, when I'm closing my computer down to go and get the kids from school, that's a classic transition where I really notice this. You know, I've been in a mode where I'm trying to do thinking, access kind of clever thought
你可能开始感到真正被困住，无法想象如何挣脱，这就是你产生关于如何真正逃离你正在做的事情的逃避主义想法的地方。现在，一天中的过渡点通常是这方面的一个很好的标志。如果你想想你完成某项事情的那一刻，比如对我来说，当我关闭电脑去学校接孩子时，那是一个典型的过渡期，我真的注意到了这一点。你知道，我一直处于一种试图思考、获取某种聪明的思考模式
stuff from writing or working on something. And then I've got to kind of go drive, get the kids. And I often find I have a telltale sign that I'm in this kind of stage of burnout when I get to the school and feel really irritable, unable to really connect with where I am and what I'm doing. So the kids might be asking me very reasonable questions about, you know, what we're doing after school. And I kind of feel like they're annoying little flies buzzing around me, but really in my own head. So this transition point is maybe something for you to think about as well, you struggling to initiate the next activity efficiently, you know, this could be starting or finishing work, but it could either be other things like mealtimes, or when you put the kids
来自写作或处理某事的思维模式。然后我必须去开车接孩子。我经常发现，当我到达学校并感到非常烦躁、无法真正连接我在哪里以及我在做什么时，我有一个处于这种倦怠阶段的显着标志。所以孩子们可能会问我非常合理的问题，你知道，我们在放学后做什么，我感觉他们就像嗡嗡叫在我周围烦人的小苍蝇，但实际上在我自己的脑海里。所以这个过渡点也许也是你可以思考的事情，你是否在努力高效地发起下一个活动，你知道，这可能是开始或结束工作，但它也可能是其他事情，比如用餐时间，或者当你把孩子
to bed, that's another time for me, you know, rather than sitting and feeling like I can snuggle with them and read, I feel like irritable that I just want to get through bedtime really quickly, and I'm not able to really engage with it. The final thing I just want to add to this as a sign is that you might feel really alone with all of this as well. So hold on to that feeling. Right, number five, we've got habitual burnout now. This is the burnout that is much more established and set in. All those signs of distress might be really shouting at you now. And clinical burnout is when your body just forces that stop. It's been asking and begging you to stop and you haven't. And so now it just says, I'm not proceeding anymore. So
送上床睡觉时，对我来说那是另一个时间，你知道的，与其坐着觉得我可以和他们依偎在一起阅读，我感到很烦躁，我只想快点把睡前时光过完，我无法真正参与其中。我只想对此补充的最后一件事是一个迹象，即你可能也会对此感到非常孤独。所以请记住这种感觉。好了，第五阶段，我们现在有了习惯性倦怠。这是更加确立和根深蒂固的倦怠。所有这些痛苦的迹象现在可能真的在对你大喊大叫。临床倦怠是指你的身体强迫你停下来。它一直在要求和乞求你停下来，而你没有。所以现在它只是说，我再也不前进了。所以
you might have this experience of struggling to get out of bed. I've also worked with people who have had non-epileptic attack disorder, so seizures that aren't explained by epilepsy or panic attacks that just completely floor them. I've also had people who haven't been able to speak, who struggle to find words or actually talk. So there could be all sorts of different, very intense physical signs of stress. And this is when often people are signed off work sick for a period of time. So I hope the message is coming across
你可能会有这种难以起床的经历。我也曾与患有非癫痫发作障碍的人合作过，也就是不能用癫痫解释的发作，或者完全压垮他们的恐慌发作。我也遇到过无法说话、难以找到词汇或实际说话的人。所以可能会有各种各样非常强烈的身体压力迹象。这就是人们经常请病假一段时间的时候。所以我希望这个信息能够传达出来
from this stage model, that it's more helpful to think of burnout on a continuum rather than a I either have it or I don't type of concept. What we use to continuums in psychology. So I'm sure this isn't a new idea. The important thing is to think about what you need at each stage. Really early on when you don't have any signs of burnout, but you're not pacing yourself. This is something to think about. This boom bust pattern is really common for people. What can you do to prevent this happening? Are
从这个阶段模型来看，将倦怠看作是一个连续体，而不是“我有或没有”的概念，会更有帮助。我们在心理学中习惯了连续体。所以我确信这不是一个新想法。重要的是思考你在每个阶段需要什么。在很早的时候，当你没有任何倦怠迹象，但你没有把握节奏时。这是需要考虑的事情。这种“繁荣-萧条”模式对人们来说非常普遍。你能做些什么来防止这种情况发生？
there people in your team, you know, a partner, a colleague who can help you stay in check? So for example, my husband knows I get like this. And he's often the one saying, have you thought about X? So often just answering, asking me that question, we've got this agreement that he will do this for me, helps me to kind of check myself out. Actually, I'm not going to have time to say, do all these things I'm saying yes to. So pacing yourself, and then also making sure you're you've got things in your diary that you just focus on and prioritize, even sure you're you've got things in your diary that you just focus on and prioritize even when you don't feel like doing it for your self-care so that might be the exercise class it might be a telephone call with a friend making sure that these even if
你团队中是否有人，你知道的，伴侣、同事可以帮助你保持检查？例如，我丈夫知道我变成了这样。他经常是那个说：“你想过X吗？”的人。所以通常只要回答、问我这个问题，我们达成了一项协议，他会为我这样做，这有助于我检查自己。实际上，我没有时间去说，去做我答应的所有这些事情。所以掌控节奏，然后还要确保你的日程表里有你只关注和优先考虑的事情，即使确保你在日程表中有些事情，即使你不想为自我照顾去做，你也会专注于优先考虑它们，所以那可能是锻炼课，可能是给朋友打电话，确保这些即使
they're just shorter you're still doing something along those lines because those are the things are going to keep you protected and they help you keep perspective as well because when we just throw ourselves into work, we do more and more work, that perspective is really hard to hold on to. Of course, later up the stages, two, three and four, this is all where we need to tend to our physiology, tend to our nervous system to keep it soothed and managed
它们很短，你仍然在做类似的事情，因为这些事情会保护你，它们也有助于你保持视角，因为当我们只是把自己投入到工作中时，我们做了越来越多的工作，那个视角真的很难保持。当然，在后面的阶段，二、三和四，这些都是我们需要照顾我们的生理机能、照顾我们的神经系统以使其保持舒缓和管理的地方，
and little pockets throughout the day are the best time to do that. So I'm going to focus on that in the next episode with you. In the final stage of burnout, this is where you need a proper break from work. If you can set things up or ask someone to help you set up, getting everything delegated so that you're not having to do things anymore. You know, often if people are off work, that starts to happen anyway. But it is trickier if your burnout is linked to, you you know being a student or being at home with your family it's important to let people know that you're not able to do all of the usual activities and tasks that you usually are able to it takes time to recover from clinical burnout where your body is forced to stop this is highly traumatic for the body and it also can be traumatic for you to have this idea
全天的小块时间是这样做的最佳时间。所以我将在下一集的节目中与你重点讨论这一点。在倦怠的最后阶段，这是你需要从工作中得到适当休息的地方。如果你能安排好事情或者请人帮你在安排上把所有东西都委派出去，这样你就不用再做事了。你知道，通常如果人们不上班，这种情况无论如何都会开始发生。但如果你的倦怠与你是一名学生或与家人呆在家里有关，那就更棘手了，重要的是让人们知道你无法完成你通常能够完成的所有常规活动和任务。从临床倦怠中恢复需要时间，因为你的身体被迫停下来，这对身体来说是高度创伤性的，而且对于你有这种想法来说，这也是创伤性的
that I'm not infallible. I do have a pause point where I can't go beyond. So you need to be really gentle with yourself at this point and encourage other people around you to learn about burnout so that they can be gentle with you too. You don't want to be trying to do this all on your own. Maybe they could read my book. That might be helpful for them to understand it so that they can support you. This brings us to the end of this episode. We're going to go a little more into detail in the practicalities of pacing and how to do that in the transition points of your day in the next episode. So come back to episode five for more on this. Oh gosh, thank you so much, Dr. Claire. How wonderful to have that broken down into those
“我不是不会犯错的。我确实有一个无法超越的暂停点。”所以在这个时候你需要对你自己非常温柔，并鼓励你周围的人了解倦怠，以便他们也能对你温柔。你不想一个人去尝试所有这些。也许他们可以读我的书。这对他们理解它以便他们能够支持你可能会有所帮助。这就到了本集节目的尾声。我们将在下一集中更详细地探讨节奏的实用性以及如何在一天中的过渡点做到这一点。所以请回到第五集了解更多关于这方面的内容。哦天哪，非常感谢克莱尔博士。很高兴能把它分解成那些
stages that makes it so accessible and so memorable so that we can start to notice what our patterns are. But I love the idea of giving people permission in your world to help you stay on track, to keep you as well as possible. And I absolutely resonate with some of that kind of run out of window of tolerance stuff. And I absolutely resonate with some of that running out of patience and tolerance at the end of the day and not being able to fully immerse myself in what can be quite a special time, putting my children to bed. Sometimes I'm just like, I just need you gone. I just need you in bed so that I can just sit and kind of decompress a bit. I would love to know what this episode has evoked for you. Please do let me know by dropping me a comment if you're
阶段，这使得它如此平易近人、令人难忘，以便我们能够开始注意到我们的模式是什么。但我喜欢这个想法，即在你的世界里给人们许可来帮助你保持正轨，让你尽可能保持健康。我绝对能引起共鸣的是那种情绪窗口耗尽的东西。我绝对能引起共鸣的是一天结束时失去耐心和容忍度，无法完全沉浸在可以成为一段相当特别的时光中，也就是哄我的孩子睡觉。有时我只是觉得：“我只需要你们离开。我只需要你们上床睡觉，这样我就可以坐下来稍微减压一下。”我很想知道这集节目对你有什么触动。如果你
watching on YouTube. If you are listening on Spotify, you can drop comments in there too. And please do come and let me know on socials. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. I'm sure Dr. Claire would also love to know what you think too. She is Dr. Claire Plumley everywhere. Come and join the free Facebook group, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. That is the exclusive home of the Marianne's Motivation and Mindset free sessions that happen weekly. If you are loving this special series on burnout, please do consider grabbing a copy of Claire's book, which you can do by searching in the show notes.
在YouTube上观看，请给我留个评论，让我知道。如果你在Spotify上收听，你也可以在那里留下评论。请务必来社交媒体上告诉我。我到处都是Dr Marianne Trent。我确信克莱尔博士也会很想知道你的想法。她到处都是Dr Claire Plumley。快来加入免费的Facebook群组“有抱负的心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。那是每周举办的“玛丽安的动机与心态”（Marianne's Motivation and Mindset）免费课程的独家主页。如果你喜欢这个关于倦怠的特别系列，请考虑购买一本克莱尔的书，你可以在节目说明中搜索来做到这一点。
We cover loads of brilliant topics in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. There's also really great reflections and ideas for career options in both the Clinical Psychologist Collective book and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. And if you've already read either or both of those, please do consider leaving me a review on both Amazon and Goodreads as it really does help us to reach a wider audience. If you are a fan of any podcast, this one especially, please do subscribe. Please do follow the show as it's the kindest free thing you can do for any podcaster that you really rate. The next episode will be available for you from 10 a.m on saturday on youtube and from 6 a.m on monday wherever you get your podcasts thank you so much for being part of my world and i will see
我们在“有抱负的心理学家会员”（Aspiring Psychologist membership）中涵盖了大量精彩的主题，你只需每月30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。在《临床心理学家集锦》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）书和《有抱负的心理学家集锦》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）书中，也有非常棒的反思和对职业选择的想法。如果你已经阅读过其中一本或两本，请考虑在亚马逊和Goodreads上给我留下评论，因为这确实有助于我们接触到更广泛的受众。如果你是任何播客的粉丝，尤其是这个播客，请务必订阅。请务必关注这个节目，因为这是你能为你真正赞赏的任何播客所能做的最友善的免费事情。下一集将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，周一上午6点在你获取播客的任何地方发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我将
you very soon take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that you're sad to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that,
很快见到你，保重。如果你正在寻找成为一名心理学家的道路，那么让这成为你的指南，通过这档播客，你将稳步走上获得资格的道路，这就是由玛丽安主持的《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我叫贾娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容真的很有趣。有很多不同的途径可以到达那里，而且没有完美的方式可以成为其中一员，这让我感到惊讶。这让我充满信心，
no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对建议你看这本书，以让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。